[Music]
danny yeah had a chance to read that
article you sent me what do you think
you don't feel like it comes off a
little tone deaf
offensive even i don't feel like you
take me seriously as a writer that's
because you're not a writer
you're a photo editor
have you ever wanted to be noticed so
badly hey mom you wanna hang out tonight
[Music]
you didn't even care what it was for
holland oh [ __ ] what up bunny danny from
work danny yo carlin i love your videos
man
thanks b
so what are you i'm a writer
i'm looking to develop my work by
traveling
going to paris for it
[ __ ]
hey get picked i'm gonna get lots of
pics yeah i'll throw them all up on the
ground right
[ __ ]
emma i got invited to a writer's retreat
in paris
yes really
starting my morning right now where's my
baguette
[Music]
we have some breaking news at this hour
a string of terrorist attacks struck
paris this morning
leaving dozens dead and many more
injured
[ __ ]
like 26.77 now arriving danny
she's okay
we are here with the girl of the moment
you've been blowing up our instability
speaking of bombings
really guys you're not good me too
isn't she so strong everybody
[Applause]
oh my god you're the girl from the paris
attack
let's not forget the signature red beret
hi i'm danny rowan welcome to group
we're all survivors here do you want to
share
you're not okay that's okay
the internet likes to turn victims into
villains
doesn't seem to be happening to me
you should be prepared if it does
we need to talk
be careful what you [ __ ] wish for
so what are we supposed to feel bad for
you
[Music]
you